so I'm not exactly sure why but you all
love a top-five list and it's crazy to
me although now that I think about it I
think a lot of the reason why is because
I think a lot of you are curious to see
whether or not my list matches your list
because that's the same attitude I take
like if I'm looking at a top-five list I
say well you know I mean if their list
matches mine then that's awesome because
they were right and if their list
doesn't match mine it's like well that
sucks because they were wrong but at any
event because you guys seem to love top
5 list so much I figured why not
dedicate a day to it so in addition to
the return of comics requests Monday
starting next week what we're going to
do is we're going to kick off this week
with the establishment of top 5 Tuesday
what we're going to go through and we're
going to make a top 5 list of any one
particular thing the top 5 best lanterns
the top 5
Superman moments and in this video we're
going to be doing the top 5 moments of
Thanos the mad Titan so number 5 on our
list come to the forum of the Infinity
event now during this conflict Thanos
was basically traversing the universe
and attempting to kill off all of its
offspring and this ultimately led him to
arriving on the planet earth and to
confronting the Inhumans and the
Inhumans city of Attilan now because
Black Bolt was still the ruler of the
Inhumans at this time this led to a
direct conflict between Black Bolt
and an Thanos himself now as we know
with our video about black bolts
character Black Bolt has a quasi sonic
screen which is immensely powerful
I guess capable of destroying planets
but it's also the reason why he can't
talk he has no real control over it if
he opens his mouth things get destroyed
and so what happens is that while this
ultimately leads to a confrontation
between Black Bolt and Thanos black ball
basically screams as loud as he possibly
can and two things happen the first is
that the Terrigen bomb detonates
spreading the Terrigen mists all over
the planet Earth and actually causing
somewhat of a reduction in the powers of
Black Bolt but the second thing that
happens is that Thanos withstands the
full scream of Black Bolt and so this to
me is incredibly impressive because it
simply means that Thanos is immensely
powerful far more powerful than the
Incredible Hulk where these that is a
normal state not fully enraged but what
is
happening here is a Thanos in response
to a black bolt basically refusing to
tell Thanos where his son is that also
grabs the head of black bolt tells him
to take his secrets to the grave and
smashes his head into the ground it is
one of the coolest moments in the entire
infinity of it at least I think it is as
one of the coolest things it was
probably one of my one of my top five
moments and the Infinity event proper
now coming in at number four on our list
is actually a really interesting one
this is one that I actually didn't learn
about until pretty recent in fact when I
was making this top-five list what
happened is that in 1974 Marvel began to
produce a series of spider-man related
stories that were for kids they weren't
really for teenagers anymore they were
targeting the younger children as a way
to bring them in to the popularity of
spider-man and so what they release was
a series called Spidey super stories now
in issue number 39 and what happens here
is the cosmic u falls into the hands of
one of Marvel's oldest characters a
woman named Patricia Walker or at least
su2 furled referred to the cat or
sometimes Hellcat but what is up
happening here is if Thanos arrives in a
stano's copter it's literally a
helicopter that says Thanos on the side
of it it's actually pretty cool and
Thanos basically tries to take the
Cosmic Cube away from Patricia but what
is up happening here is that Patricia
and spider-man team up and they're
ultimately able to stop Thanos and the
result as if Thanos was actually
arrested by police and he's taken to
jail so again this is targeted towards
kids this is targeted towards you know
very young kids but I thought it was
pretty awesome it was pretty funny to
see fan OHS the mad Titan the destroyer
of worlds to see him arrested and taken
to jail so coming in at the number 3
spot on our list comes during the
Infinity Gauntlet event and you guys had
to know infinity gamma was going to be
in here somewhere
you could not have a top 5 list that
housed moments without having something
from the Infinity Gauntlet and this
particular instance comes from the event
whereby Thanos after I guess attaining
the Infinity Gauntlet assembling the
gems in the form of the gullet itself
but he basically went through and
fulfilled the request that mistress
death gave him that led him to gaining
the infinity gems for the second time in
the first place what he does without
displaying any kind
of crazy stuff he doesn't blow up
planets he doesn't use fireworks or any
kind of flashy gaudy things he simply
just walks to the edge of the shrine
looks around and then snaps his fingers
and when he does he eliminates half the
life in the universe 50% of all life I
guess human beings and aliens and plants
and planets and all kinds of stuff half
of it just gone just totally phase out
of existence as if it was never there in
the first place that is nuts that is
absolutely insane that is probably the
one thing that Thanos has remembered for
during the Infinity Gauntlet event more
so than anything else and fingers
crossed guys fingers crossed hopefully
we'll actually see this during the
infinity war in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe so rounding out our list and
the number two spot is the heart of
infinite power or some people refer to
it the heart of the universe now in this
story what that has deado status he
basically captured the heart of the
universe he captured the power of the
one above all and in doing so he
basically destroyed everything and it
was really cool because what he said was
that were the Infinity Gauntlet gave him
absolute power over manipulating the
very facets of reality or the very
fastest of the universe that the heart
of the universe itself was basically
making him or at least it did make him
the universe itself and so he was no
longer manipulating something he was
that something and so it's kind of hard
to differentiate in terms of what the
power levels are or I guess what the
differences is differences are in terms
of what he could do with these two
things but what this basically meant was
that he was able to wipe out everything
I mean he wiped out the Living Tribunal
he wiped out all the cosmic entities he
even destroyed the multiverse there
actually came a point when it was simply
just a void of blackness and he was the
only thing in and the only people who
are protected from him were Kimora and
Adam warlock and somebody else I can't
remain here that Adam warlock actually
appears to Thanos and says this is dumb
and you're dumb for doing it like you
need friends you need people in your
life you need at the very least
individuals you can fight just for the
sake of saying that you can fight them
and kill them and so thatís agrees and
Thanos ends up just setting everything
back to normal
he wasn't defeated like no one defeated
him he simply just set everything back
to normal
he got bored basically and said okay
let's set everything back to the way it
was which to me is ridiculous in terms
of the scope of power the fan OHS had
and so here's the question if the
Infinity Gauntlet is number three and
this ridiculous display of power and the
heart of the universe event is number
two then what's number one well ladies
and gentlemen the number one moment in
the history of fan OSIS continuity comes
with the Great Lakes Avengers Christmas
special number one in 2005 when Thanos
appears on the planet Earth after
charging some kind of artifact with a
life force of every single person on
earth and the result is that Squirrel
Girl with her assistant tippy-toe jumps
in and saves the day in fact we don't
see how it happens all we know is that
she defeats Thanos Thanos was defeated
by Squirrel Girl like that like that
happened that really happened Thanos was
defeated by swore girl and Marvel told
us this was true Marvel through The
Watcher into it and The Watcher says
well I mean it's not a clone it's not a
robot like it is Thanos this is the real
fan OHS and it's weird that you were
able to do it but you did and that
that's it like that's how we verify the
Squirrel Girl defeated Thanos and so
what this meant was that Thanos was now
inducted into an extremely elite and
small club of people who had been
defeated by Squirrel Girl these people
include will reign they include Deadpool
Doctor Doom and more recently Galactus
without being said we're gonna go ahead
and bring this video to an end and let
me know what your all's number one
favorite moment is let me know what your
favorite moment from all of Pharos
entirety continuity is because I'm very
curious to see what you all come up with
with that being said I will catch you
guys later peace